So here's an example that we're going to
use to kind of motivate this idea.
So here's a representation of a POMDP.
It's got how many states?
>> Four.
>> Good.
It's got how many observations?
Three!
Right, blue, green, and red.
And so these two states
are indistinguishable by their
immediate observations.
And let's say there's four actions,
north, south, east, west.
So north from this red
takes you to this green,
north from this red
takes you to this blue.
East and west from this blue
leave you where you were, etc.
Does that make some sense?
>> Yes.
>> So we've got left, right, up, down as
our actions and these four states and
these three possible observations.
And so we can represent this as a POMDP.
If we know these dynamics,
we know this system, we know this model,
we can represent what's the probability
we're in each of these states, one, two,
three, four, the states.
And so for example, if I say okay, I'm
going to start off uniformly at random.
And by the way,
the state you're in is currently red.
So then our belief state would be
what zero, zero, a half, a half.
If we then go left, then our
belief state would be zero, zero,
a half, a half still.
>> Right.
>> If we went up and observed green,
then our probability distribution
would be zero, one, zero, zero.
We'd definitely be in this state.
And actually, given that there's
no stochasticity in this case,
we would know where we were
forever after, right, and
we would continue to act and
we'll know where we are.
We're going to to try to re-represent
the same idea, the same system, the same
model, but not using a POMDP but
instead by using a set of predictions.
So I'm going to claim that the tests
that we're going to use for
this representation, well,
there's lots of possibilities, but
we're going to do is say, hey,
what would happen if you were to go up?
Would you see blue?
So what's the probability that
you'd see blue after going up?
And if you were to go left,
would you see red?
What's the probability of
seeing red if we were to go
left from the current state?
And so again,
the state is going to be predictions.
It's going to be probabilities
on these two quantities, and
we're going to try to keep that updated.
We're going to keep these
predictions updated as we move
around in the environment.
>> Okay, so we're replacing
a distribution over states with
a kind of distribution over the outcomes
of tests that we might take.
>> Yeah, I think that's
a good way to think about it.
Probabilities that we get here
don't necessarily have to add up to
one, right?
That's sort of independent,
the question of how likely is
it to see blue when we go up?
How likely is it to see
red after we go left?
But other than that,
it is a sort of probabilistic quantity.
But we kind of like this notion that
these tests are actions and observations
because in any given time, we could say,
hey, this seems like the kind of
situation where it's two-thirds
probable that I go up and see blue.
Let's just try that just to make sure.
So we can go up, see whether or
not we see blue, and
see how often that
actually seems to happen.
It's still not trivial
to learn in this case,
but at least it's grounded out in
observables, actions, and observations.
>> Right, and I guess sort of
philosophically, if I might
wax philosophical for a moment, there's
really no difference between this and
states, right, because states
are kind of made up things,
which represent states of the world,
dare I say it.
Then these tests also kind of represent,
at least implicitly,
other states of the world and are just
as fine a reasonable representation
as these made up nominal circles.
>> Yeah,
they're not certainly no worse, but
I'm going to argue that in principle,
they might even be better.
Because again,
you can actually execute these tests and
see what the outcomes were.
>> And then that will tell you where
you were and possibly where you are.
>> Yeah, or at least would let you
validate your current predictions.
Whereas with states, if I think,
okay, I'm in the belief state zero,
a half, a half to zero,
there's nothing that you can validate.
There's no test that you can run.
There's no experiment you can do
in the world that would tell you
what the states actually were
because states are not observable.
>> But these tests can tell
you sort of whether you are,
I'm going to try to ground
this out an example.
So, am I sick,
do I have a particular disease?
Well, there are tests that I
could run that would tell me, and
then I might be able to do
other more interesting things.
And that's kind of a practical thing to
know, rather than asking the question, I
mean, it's one way of sort of answering
an underlying question of am I in
the state of being sick or in the state
of, I don't know, having blue hay fever.
>> [LAUGH] I guess that's
this upper left state.
>> Yeah, so I'm intrigued,
so what's next?
What do we do with these tests?
>> Well, so in principle, we should
be able to learn PSR representations.
And because again, if we have a test,
we should be able to validate it and
make our predictions better over time.
And in principle, we could plan
in this kind of space as well.
We're not going to talk about
either of those in the class, but
I do want to do a slightly more concrete
example of these test probabilities with
this little grid that we've got going
here, just to make it more concrete.
>> Okay.